jean luc mélenchon à dire que nous
allions bouffer de la reine pendant dix
jours formule bête et méchante qui
traduit sa vulgarité dan sans doute mais
qui illustre l'esprit de quelques-uns
dans ce pays ce mauvais esprits qui
gangrène le pays nourri de passions
tristes de rancoeur et de rose sentiment
pauvre jean luc mélenchon hermétique à
la noblesse des sentiments
sobre
et ça tombait déjà un faux pas pour
charles iii à la cérémonie de
proclamation du nouveau roi d'angleterre
des internautes ont repéré ce geste de
la main un brun dédaigneux pour compte
débarrasse un encrier de la table la
séquence cumule plus de 25 millions de
vu et lui vaut d'être qualifié de roi
désagréable avec le petit personnel
esclaves débarrasser moi ce bureau en
2022 un juan ne peut plus tout se
permettre surtout s'il veut être
populaire un sacré déconneur qui a
volontiers classe et son image d'aristo
coin sauce comme ici lorsqu'il enflamme
le dancefloor lors d'une battle
[Musique]
un passé de break dancer donc mais aussi
de djette puisque c'est probablement le
seul roi d'angleterre qu'on aura vu
scratch et des vinyles
[Musique]
lui inconditionnels de la monarchie n'a
pas attendu oui j'ai bien dormi il a
planté sa tente il y a trois jours
devant des kings and palaces pour être
sûr de ne rien manquer
de toute façon moi je ne veux pas aller
à l'hôtel je veux faire mon deuil ici
dans ma tente je ne veux pas te comfort
tant pis si c'est à la dure c'est comme
ça que je veux rendre hommage à la reine
75 livres la nuit c'est un bed and
breakfast 150 et vous pourrez avoir un
corps y est avec vous tout
il existe une à mon effigie oui j'espère
avec bientôt la poupée ken françois
hollande curieuse d'en apprendre plus
sur la vie au village ses bras dessus
bras dessous que les rivales d'hier
accompagne jeanine dans son palais où
l'entrée est gardée par son chat macron
deligey
c'est une jolie petite bourgade de
données sonnent et d'ailleurs ne loupez
pas la traditionnelle fête de la
châtaigne ça aura lieu le dimanche 16
octobre pour vous inscrire julien 7 en
mairie avant le 7 octobre sinon il y
aura pas de place et donc sur des
ballades du spectacle de fauconnerie des
ateliers et sans oublier le concours du
poids de châtaignes et les châtaignes le
coeur au concours de fauconnerie sachez
que tous les bateaux dans cette émission
c'est encore si
on rit moins qu'avant on passe en
moyenne seulement une minute par jour à
rire contre 19 minutes par jour en 1939
et six minutes en 1983 et ouais c'est
comme ça et lui ouais absolument non
c'est bien connu c'est bien connu c'est
bien connu est donc l'une des raison
justement invoqué ce serait que le rire
et le mot ne sont pas vraiment des
qualités qu'on met en avant dans
l'époque dans laquelle on est il n'y a
pas eu beau mener très bien
sur vous n'êtes plus révisé me faire
engueuler d'accord mais yann donc vous
vous arrêtez de m'engueuler maintenant
vous engueuler paillade lycée papillon
et rich
media non mais c'est pas parce qu'il est
arrêté de m'engueuler d'abord toulouse
en gueule pas malgré d'eric zemmour dit
quelque chose qui fait en rien j'ai
choisi moureaux log je suis pas venu ici
à désert la publicité et eric zemmour on
dirait qu'il fait et vous arrêtez de
m'engueuler je vous engueuler pont
j'aime les hirondelles il ya de la joie
dans le ciel par dessus le toit ya la
joie et du soleil dans les ruelles ya de
la joie partout gala vous avez trois
quarts des salariés français qui estime
par exemple que l'humour n'est pas assez
valorisé au travail alors je ne sais pas
si c'est le cas ici mais en tout cas
voilà ce que pensent les salariés
français mais alors cette crise du rire
elle a des conséquences et ben
absolument elle a des conséquences
d'abord sur notre stress vous avez 40 %
des français qui se sentent aujourd'hui
déprimé et c'est un chiffre qui a doublé
en l'espace de cinq ans pascal enfin
parce que vous avez essayé combien de
fois vous d'être maïs trop gelé t il à
hiverner c'est pas vrai oui j'étais un
petit match trop je vois que je ne vous
ai pas marqué ah ça je vous confirme oui
il y à ok donc il faut pas dû répéter
ici il faut faire comme à la télé faut
dire faut maintenant faut toujours dire
la guerre je suis tellement heureux de
vous retrouver vous m'avez manqué pour
en revenir à jean luc mélenchon s'y fait
des crises de nerfs c'est parce que vous
savez la mégalomanie ça existe est ce
que regrette jean-luc mélenchon sait que
ce n'est pas lui qui soit célébré 24
heures sur 24
et je ne suis pas sûr que les drapeaux
français soit en berne le jour de son
départ